now about 10 of the population gets
these little stones
in their tonsils and so today we're
going to talk about how to prevent
tonsil stones and then if you get tonsil
stones and you go to your dentist and
they remove them
how to prevent them from coming back now
to understand tonsil stones we have to
understand what the tonsil is
the tonsil is in a first line of defense
it's a tissue very similar to a lymph
node it's in the back of the throat and
it's there to prevent pathogens from
going deeper inside the body and tonsils
produce t cells which is part of the
immune system and so they will capture
detect and then start developing a
defense against a certain microbe that
might be in your mouth or in your
environment so that's what the tonsils
are and the stone part
are basically something called biofilms
okay biofilms and
biofilms are little
calcium igloos
that microbes specifically with this
situation it's bacteria that's living in
these little
cement-like igloos and that's really
what they are they're basically cement
houses to protect them from being
destroyed by antibiotics and so a
biofilm is a shield it's a defense
mechanism to help these microbes survive
and these microbes also produce a gas
like a sulfur gas that's why
people that have tonsil stones have a
bad odor in their mouth like sometimes
rotten eggs
they might have a metallic taste they
might get a cough and these stones
usually develop after kind of a chronic
tonsillitis or being on antibiotics for
a period of time because that will wipe
out your defenses and then increase your
pathogens and i keep hitting this point
across over and over my videos you have
all this good bacteria it's called the
microbiome and you don't want to get rid
of it you don't want to sterilize it if
you kill it off with antibiotics you
better replace it because these microbes
help defend against pathogens and other
microbes that make biofilms so anything
that increases chronic tonsillitis will
increase
these biofilms so if a person was on
steroids
if they're diabetic if they
consume a lot of sugar
if they're zinc deficient if they're
vitamin d deficient
all these factors
weaken your immune system and increase
the chance of getting these stones and
biofilms are not just living in the
crevices of your tonsils they're also in
like 59 of sinus infections they're
involved in ear infections they're
involved in utis they're involved
infections throughout the body so it is
a major defense mechanism that certain
pathogens use to survive so there are
three things
to do as remedies to help prevent these
things from coming back and this mainly
is going to act as a natural antibiotic
without the side effects so it kills the
pathogens but it doesn't kill the good
guys so number one garlic you want to
consume a lot of garlic okay on a
regular basis number two
oregano oil oregano oil is a very
powerful
natural antibiotic but it virtually does
nothing to our good bacteria
and number three and this is a real
powerful one as well and i'll put the
links down below that support
the data that i'm talking about
but grape fruit seed extract okay
another great natural antibiotic now of
course there's a couple other things
that contribute to this as well
being on a high carb diet and consuming
a lot of
dairy products that can create more
mucus especially if you're a young
person and you get chronic
inflammation of the tonsils or ear
infections or even a sinus infection
anyone who has upper or lower
respiratory infections
needs to get off dairy now the next most
important video for you to watch right
now is the one on the immune system in
relationship to zinc and vitamin d
check it out i put it up right here